how do you feel about antitrust um
investigations into these big tech
companies
i i mean yeah so in general i'm
skeptical that uh i mean i i've watched
all the hearings um i'm skeptical that
you can really apply antitrust as it ex
if you changed antitrust then they might
fall under it but for antitrust it has
to be
there has to be a harm from a consumer
standpoint it can't just be that they
have all this influence and power and
everybody just uses their service
it also has to have a material a
downside from the from the
from the customer well like like banning
minds don't really
yeah i do so you can't but you really
can't show that with
for the maybe it's bad for mines but
it's not bad for for the consumer
because there's no
it's not like i have to pay more for
more expensive bananas because facebook
has cornered the market on bananas or
something
that so it's not going to work under the
existing antitrust
now so i think that's true for facebook
um
apple is no one even really seems to be
asserting that it's a monopoly it makes
a product that just goes
with other products google has done
you know so i approach these things with
an open mind i'm generally a free market
guy
um google sound like they did some shady
stuff
that got brought up that i didn't know
about um the thing with what with yelp
was it
um do you know what i'm talking about no
i don't well i i'm not
100 that they there's some dispute there
i think it was with yelp that they that
they treated them badly they wanted to
i i i don't remember exactly enough so i
don't want to i mean
there's some other stuff and i know the
the right the the the putting
conservative sites on a list and then
they suddenly disappear from the google
search results
which they did sometimes conservatives
get this wrong because your google
results are different
depending on what you've searched but it
and they fixed it quickly but it was
still weird that they it must be like
some
it was accidental but there's some
switch they could flip why are people on
a
so i guess like i'm not you know i'm not
totally denying the
the there are any of these problems but
i don't really think anyway i don't
think breaking up these companies would
would improve matters yeah i i don't
disagree um
i i mostly agree that it won't improve
things especially when you consider that
some of these platforms you know youtube
for instance can't exist
outside of google itself right because
it's subsidized by
a lot of these other things but uh
here's an example it's interesting
my two my two of my channels tim cast
news and tim cast
are blacklisted from google they will
not appear
in fact if you search for the title
you'll get facebook videos instead
but this channel will and i don't
exactly know why that is
it could be that this channel is
relatively new from this year and there
was a point where youtube created a list
and they
straight up eliminated a lot of these
channels from their search interestingly
a lot of the people who got eliminated
tend to be
individuals promoting alternative
platforms
right i mean it could be it could also
be that's just what the algorithm thinks
people want when they search these
things
well no like my channel literally
doesn't come up on any page at all
it's just outright banned so if you
search for tim cast on google you'll get
this channel
which is new and my other channels just
don't exist you'd think that if you
if you could actually limit the google
search to site or you do
site colon youtube.com so that all
search only goes to youtube won't come
up
it's literally blacklisted interestingly
like i mentioned
many of the people who have been are on
this blacklist there's
a lot of uh personalities independent
commentators
they're all people who either have
supported say like minds or bit shoot or
other
social big other social media platforms
well sudden we find ourselves on a list
where
you can't google searches anymore i'm
currently writing a
book about the regulation of speech on
social media and i'm trying to get a
hold of google so i will ask them
if i ever do i've asked them too and
they just like don't have any answers
yeah they're like huh that's strange
we'll look into it and they they know
whatever happens
yeah it's weird because i certainly
don't think they hate me
like i'm rather successful on the
platform you know especially this
channel is doing really really well
and they and and it does come up i don't
know what it is
maybe it was a rogue employee you know
oops it was a mistake and they put your
name on a list or something i think
companies do make mistakes absolutely my
my concern
as and and i think there's a really
interesting contrast between you as a
libertarian and me as more of a liberal
right i'm like when yeah this is that is
what the contrast is here
i'm all like regulate the company
they're they're interfering with public
and you're like no free market
yeah i think it's great though because
it's really funny how for them i think
we
we actually agree on on so much stuff
especially pertaining to like the
radical left and the insanity
and they've somehow created this like
big tent of liberals libertarians
conservatives
moderates whatever opposed to them for
the most part like we all get along
hanging out we're like yes we
we disagree on so much we don't talk
about anymore you know what i mean yep
but i am and i am also always happy to
call out you know bad behavior by these
companies
yeah when i see people get banned for
stupid reasons you can come to me i will
share your story i will look into it um
i
i think that's the method for holding
them accountable i'm just i'm worried
actually about harming conservative
speech if you actually
harmed me i can't force completely agree
with that like if you got rid of 230
independent creators would be
totally screwed uh actually a friend of
mine uh casey maddox tweeted it because
donald trump said something about
getting rid of 230 or something today he
tweeted he did it again
and uh and casey maddox tweeted so
here's what it would look like
thank you donald trump for submitting
this tweet we will subject it to review
and it will appear on our platform
within four days
yeah it'll be way way worse i just think
uh
i'm in favor of reform particularly to
clarify
what the terms of good faith moderation
really mean that might be fine yeah
because
banning someone for saying learn to code
the the the bigger issue at hand for me
is that if you facebook really wanted to
they could guarantee victory to any
candidate
yeah um but i think that would just be
so bad for their
like i think they wouldn't do that but
well they banned some of the highest
profile trump supporters
a year ago but and would that even give
like
then they would they could just they
could go full msnbc or full fox and be
so in the tank for one
youtubers that right but that already
well actually everything is that
phenomenon already exists
because there's already rabidly partisan
information outlets spewing selective or
biased or even
outright disinformation and it's the
world it's just the world it's always
been the world we live in i mean there
would think of
like the the the newspaper where you
would get all your information
used to be called like the republican or
the democrat yeah i mean
like partisan insanity or yellow journal
i mean remember the main goal if you're
gonna go back far enough
there's a long history of this kind of
thing i do i don't think
the the problem is different because it
involves different pla
methods of delivery of information i'm
not sure it's actually
notably different in the kind of thing i
think youtube is the best
yeah and i explained this a lot that if
you go to youtube you can actually get a
progressive liberal moderate
uh conservative you know individual you
can actually hear what a lot of them
have to say
and there's actually even some
relatively far-right individuals who
have
survived on the platform for quite some
time although they're the the first to
get the axe
if if you if you only watch like you
know some of these cable news channels
you're you're in a you know a specific
partisan building
you go on youtube you might get a mixed
bag of things the the bigger issue i see
is that
youtube not is not so much of the
problem in my opinion because um but
they are definitely going mainstream
like i think most people will get
recommended fox news videos
after they leave this stream and it's
it's interesting too because they've
done similar things to like jimmy dore
who's uh rather he's a lefty but they
recommend fox news on his channel like
crazy
so there was actually a researcher who
mapped all this and found that youtube
does everything in their power to
actually
push people towards mainstream media
that's a problem
well um i've actually i'm actually just
working on that part of
my book right now looking at the because
there was a concern among progressive
people
uh that youtube is radicalizing people
by giving them
increasingly fringe content right it's
the opposite
right uh is that they're is that they're
trying to send them more normy stuff
um actually substantially more left wing
as well
it's two to one so there's actually a
there's actually a chart that maps this
and you have to be careful because it is
it is two to one that you are more
likely to be recommended left wing
content
but it's because many mainstream
celebrities and comedians
are are making anti-trump jokes so that
the perspective you will get from them
will be
anti-trump which aligns with the left
but it is not left partisan content
so in reality it's actually if you get
rid of the late night comedy hosts while
that generic
trash you know current year comedy it's
awful
then you get us you you get a decent
lean towards youtube promoting left-wing
content
relative to right-wing content but it is
decently balanced but the rabbit hole
that's the point it leans left right but
the reality is there's not a very big
rabbit hole on youtube at all
yeah this is it's just it's so you know
where the rabbit hole really is it's
facebook
because facebook allows you to directly
share the content so what happens is you
go on facebook and this is the bigger
problem i see with these big tech
companies it's the algorithmic feeds
where you essentially have accidental
world views being built
so someone will make a video you know
police brutality
and they'll post it on facebook someone
will see it they get angry
anger is the most likely uh to trigger a
share it's the emotion that triggers
sharing the most
so they share it then facebook says they
like these words
and it keeps filter you know feedback
looping similar content into them
and they keep sharing it and so you get
this mass spread of insane police
brutality
where it actually happened where one of
the top websites in the world at one
point
literally only wrote about police
brutality it was like a website
dedicated to police brutality and it
cracked the top 500 websites in the
world
because facebook was just pumping out
like crazy
and that's that's a bigger rabbit hole
if you only ever
see police brutality then you're gonna
assume all the cops are like evil demons
hunting people down and killing them
when in reality it was we have what 300
million 370 million interactions with
cops
and a percentage of them go bad and
you'll be able to inundate someone's
feeds endlessly with this kind of
content and facebook was doing that
i think they changed a little bit but
what's worrying to me is when you see
the actual rabbit hole on youtube i
don't know if you've ever seen this
maybe i'll show you
after is uh it's a video of hitler
and he's doing he's doing tai chi with
the incredible hulk
while some people from india are singing
a nursery rhyme
into what sounds like you know some
trashy dollar store headphones
that they could only muster up as a
microphone somehow
it's nightmarishly creepy but what
happened was
parents were putting babies in you know
in their cribs or beds and giving them a
tablet
and then pressing play on nursery rhymes
and the algorithm was just grabbing
keywords
so within an hour or two it was
nightmarish nightmarish weird
it's actually really great art if you
would ask me like if it was made for an
art installation i'd be like ah
incredible the hitler dancing in a
bikini with a woman's body with the
incredible hulk while
someone sings nursery rhymes wonder what
it means
but when you show it to babies and it's
the only thing they see it's gonna start
twisting their brains
so what happens all right fine you got
me babies should not watch
videos of hitler dancing in a bikini all
right
well i'm not i'm not i'm not saying i'm
not saying pro regularly twist my arm
i'm not i'm not saying all this to be
pro regulation i'm just saying that the
company had to make changes because that
was actually happening
but here's the the main point i've i you
know i've mentioned
the problem with facebook is if if i
showed you a video
of the incredible hulk the joker and
hitler dancing together
you'd be like that's insane why is that
nursery rhyme video being shown to kids
you know it's crazy the baby doesn't
what if
we did the exact same algorithmic
manipulation
but instead of the incredible hulk
hitler and the joker i said
donald trump racism and neo-nazis and
the only thing you ever saw
was a nightmarish amalgamation of things
that just didn't really exist
so we've actually seen this in news
outlets there was one we talked about in
the show where it was like they were
making fun of them
they're like they were dragging melania
trump and they stuffed every possible
keyword into the article
because they were hoping that those
keywords would get it shared more on
like google or something
that's the danger i see with big tech
companies having algorithms that choose
certain words and weighs them and then
it results in people getting these
specific narratives
i think one of the reasons we see the
rise of the radical left in this way
is because facebook's algorithm favors
content that has more keywords in it
so why is it that police brutality did
so well anger triggered emotions but
they started mixing in the words racism
and police brutality and it got even
more shares because now it had double
the key words
same thing was true for adding sexism
and now you'll see articles from vice
saying like
trans women of trans women of color
fighting against police brutality is the
epitome of black lives matter in trump's
america
that sounds exactly like a vice headline
yeah yeah and it's like we just
jammed everything in there but then
people read that and they adopt this
ideology that seemingly has no goal and
makes no sense well that's actually a
that's a good thing to hear because that
we can fix that problem right you could
change what
uh just like it used to be upworthy
style headlines is what
dr uh drove like click bait stuff and
then there was
tweaks to algorithms and now all that
went away
because all the the crash of that kind
of content so
yeah well that's my rant on algorithm
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast
irl podcast we do the show live monday
through friday at 8pm so come back to
check us out when we go live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for free
if you want to listen to us there thanks
for hanging out and we will see you all
next time